Speaker 1: Speaking of covid persistent covid
mis manager, Republican Texas Governor Greg
Abbott has tested positive for the coronavirus.
He's reportedly isolating and he is receiving
a monoclonal antibody treatment, according
to his office.
Now, remember that this is the same Greg Abbott
who wanted to block local officials from mandating
masks, who wanted to open everything, who
was part of the administration, whose lieutenant
governor, Dan Patrick, said grandma will sacrifice
herself for the economy.
That was early in the pandemic back in 2020.
Now, you might be asking, why was Abbott even
tested, given that he is asymptomatic?
Because he's reportedly been tested daily
and he finally turned up positive for the
first time this week.
They've also announced that everybody Abbott
has been in contact with has been notified.
Now, I really wonder whether that's true,
because that is a ton of people.
Look at these videos in the video I'm playing
for you now.
This is from the last couple of days.
You see Greg Abbott indoors.
He's the one in the wheelchair in the middle
of the frame as the camera pans to the right
without a mask in a room with maybe 100 people
without masks, hugging, taking pictures, shaking
hands.
That was Monday night when he was presumably
already positive for the virus.
His positive test was yesterday.
Here's another video of Abbott on Tuesday,
yesterday on stage at a big Republican event
singing Masterclass.
We know that singing is a major spread activity.
This isn't a big crowd.
The entire crowd is actually singing.
Check this out.
Speaker 2: All right.
Speaker 1: OK, so that's that's probably enough
sorry for subjecting you to that there.
So there is Greg Abbott, presumably covid
positive singing and then here is Abbott in
a very cozy close up meeting with a supporter
of some kind of fan of his, we might say,
Marcellus Indore greeting at one of these
events.
So how many people did the Republican governor
give the virus to before he tested positive
himself?
Now, he will probably be fine.
He has the best medical care money can buy
your money, by the way.
I mean tax money.
He's getting the antibody treatment.
He's reportedly asymptomatic.
And think about that for a second.
Vaccinated and no symptoms.
And he still gets the expensive antibody treatment.
These guys are truly horrible.
Zoom out.
And it's this dystopian big picture.
They go around advocating for not taking precautions.
They say don't close anything.
Grandparents are willing to die, sacrifice
themselves for the economy.
So they take no precautions.
Tons of people in their state get sick and
die.
Then they get an asymptomatic case and immediately
get the best treatment available, even one
that would never go to an asymptomatic, vaccinated
person.
And they at least what's thought to be a good
treatment.
And then they pretend that that's proof that
we don't really need to worry about it.
Look, listen, I got the vaccine.
I didn't wear a mask.
I did my thing.
I got the expensive monoclonal antibodies
and I came out fine.
So we really don't need to worry about it,
even though that's a treatment almost none
of us would get if we were to become sick.
And he gets it all paid for by our taxes,
some federal, state, etc..
Understand that this is not a minor point.
He's fully vaccinated, he's asymptomatic,
he feels fine, but he gets the monoclonal
antibody treatment anyway.
Now, the other possibility and a few people
wrote to me saying, you know, David, maybe
it's not that he's asymptomatic and getting
the antibody treatment.
Maybe it's that they're lying, that he's asymptomatic,
he's actually really sick, but they're going
to give him that treatment anyway.
I just don't think so.
I mean, unless he the video of him around
200 people is from yesterday.
So unless he got, like, really sick late yesterday
and they already are putting him on the antibiotic,
I just don't think so.
I think that he's just getting the treatment
because he's the governor of Texas.
And by the way, you know, just just as a little
because you hear from all these anti vaccines,
the vaccine is not yet fully approved by the
FDA, sir.
Neither is the monoclonal antibody treatment.
It's approved under the very same type of
emergency use authorization that the vaccines
are.
So tons of anti vaccines.
It's funny because they say that vaccine.
No, no, no, that's not fully approved by the
FDA.
Plus, we have a great treatment.
If I did get it and I did get really sick,
we've got the monoclonal antibodies.
That's the same type of emergency use authorization.
Neither is fully approved by the FDA.
So absurd at the macro level.
Ridiculous at the micro level feeds misinformation.
And some of these governors seem determined
to just keep going, going, going until such
time that everybody in their state has Cobbett.
And the first guy that comes to mind when
I think of that is Republican Florida Governor
Rhonda Santurce.
Let's talk about him a little bit next.